[Music]
what men want
so what men want is the gender swap of
what women want what women want was a
movie starring Mel Gibson where Mel
Gibson could hear the thoughts of women
and now what men want his movie starring
Roger P handsome rich Roger P hence it
can hear men's thoughts and this is one
of those gender swats where I'm like I I
get why it happens that's been the joke
forever right like comics comedians for
decades that's been the joke when women
do lives yeah but when men do this so
making a follow up to what women want
and having it what men wanted so that's
I'm surprised it didn't happen in the
early 2000s that said you still got to
make the movie good that's just logic
everyone just felt like an exaggeration
and comedies can use hyperbole and
exaggerations for the sake of their
comedy like even dramas can do that for
the sake of drama operative concept is
for the sake comedy the comedy needs to
be funny this movie's not that fun a lot
of the jokes just fall flat some of them
are awkward Slyke I feel like that was
ad-lib it had to have been ad-lib by
someone who's not that good at
ad-libbing otherwise it's in the script
and it got passed a few people by the
time it got on-screen benefit of the
doubt I'm gonna say it was ad-lib all
the dudes in the first act of this movie
are meathead jocks except like her
assistant he's a nice guy
but everyone else is like bring some
chicks I left my neck in the parking lot
dude she's bad [ __ ] they're
exaggerations to make a point just made
the movie feel cartoony some of the
jokes are funny
I'll give it credit where credit's due
but more of them weren't in fact though
the weed selling voodoo lady she was
actually really funny she was the
funniest part of the movie not just like
oh kind of the funniest part of the
movie by a clear mile the funniest part
of the movie was Lunas choppa Lee edited
especially in one scene the poker scene
which I thought was gonna be a sweet
sink so she's gonna go in there like
Molly's game and [ __ ] and show them
what's up but the important thing about
a poker scene is you get to flesh out
the poker game but this card game I was
like I just don't give a [ __ ] it's like
they got a bunch of people to make
cameos like I just sit around a table
we're gonna montage through this thing
suite done who likes poker [ __ ] a lot
of people you could tell an endearing
tale and this movie does have an
enduring quality in it sprinkled in
there somewhere among the comedy that
falls flat on his face general concept
being she needs to learn to connect with
people but the concept that men and
women both want to be with people they
love and be respected that's in here but
a kind of wants to tell that kind of
wants to tell the tale of her show and
the dudes
our office what's up kinda wants to do
the romance thing it's just there's so
many things that wants to do that no
lesson actually comes through as the
point because if you're gonna make a
messy movie with comedy that falls flat
on his face and about three or four
lessons you want to tell but don't
really know what to tell at least make
the movie time efficient at least don't
make the movie too long movie felt way
too long but in the end I'm just gonna
say I'm not gonna remember this one than
t-minus one day ya already forgot which
is a bummer because like I said it's a
good concept but men want what women
want
just lessons are there to be learned and
comedy is there in the concept but no
not this time right so what men want
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see any
more
[Music]